the exception to the rule when you say a
lot of people also weren't able to get
access to oxytocin or xanax or whatever
the pain medication that they needed
my best friend in the world died from
vicodin and i took him to rehab for 14
days because the dentist was selling it
to him and giving it to him because he
was making money so for every one story
of somebody doesn't have access to
there's a hundred that are being abused
by doctors and many would agree with
that the numbers right there showed if
you can show the chart on opioids uh
right on what it's looking like and
what's happened the last few years david
if we can go to it this is how many
opioid
debts we used to have every year look at
the spike from 2014 and you're talking
during the obama administration when the
d.a try to crack it down to look where
it's at right now
uh with the numbers that we're having i
think even this last year we cross over
100 000 that's how we're talking about
you saw that over all over the place but
this is kind of where i want to go
hector with you and i want to go with
you as well just so the audience knows
this so number one so the drug uh
legalizing or keeping it illegal right
which ones do you worry about the most
because let's look at wheat let's look
at ecstasy let's look at crack let's
look at cocaine let's look at any of
those things let's start off there first
which of those four concerns you the
most
actually all of them because they're all
very highly addictive uh fentanyl
bothers me a lot because
you could
die on the first use of fentanyl you
don't have to be addicted and a lot of
our children are dying
you know uh they're all very dangerous
patrick
these drugs are killer drugs you can die
from using these drugs and they're so
addictive that it's very very hard
to get to be rehabilitated and be cured
uh
you know i don't have a problem with
with
people using drugs i don't think that
people that use drugs
should be arrested i think these people
should sweden and should be
rehabilitated okay okay and i'm a dea
agent i think it's wrong for uh for us
to arrest
the victims of these drug cartels anyone
and
cocaine heroin anything exactly i think
that
uh users of drug whether it be heroin
cocaine phantom i don't care i don't
think the user should be
incarcerated they should i don't think
they should be punished i think they
should be cured we should do more on
rehabilitating and curing our drug
addicts okay so
so if i if i'm at a restaurant and i'm
at denny's i'm at waffle house i'm at
chili's i say i'll have a you know cream
broccoli soup they bring it to me i
bring the chicken and i say okay thank
you so much and right there i do a line
of cocaine you're okay with that
because you're saying i'm just doing a
line of cocaine i'm not selling are you
saying you're okay if i'm using that at
a restaurant
legally i think i i i i think you
shouldn't be arrested but let me answer
that one because this is where i think
you and i are kind of on the same side
okay so let's take a look at portugal
right
portugal drug policy right now and i
think here's the thing is we have to
have this clear understanding that you
know there's
we in america
don't understand what true
decriminalization means so in portugal
they have decriminalized all drugs their
public health agency has determined the
amount of drugs that is
perfectly legal for possession right you
know x amount of days for
you know this type of drug for this type
of drug whatever it happens to be
if you're in portugal and you're you
know get that line of cocaine
you're still going to have a law
enforcement initial contact but the
decriminalization
in portugal
doesn't require you going to jail it's a
civil process they give you a ticket
they take your drugs they send you to a
dissuasion court which is non-coercive
and you show up in this dissuasion court
in order to determine whether maybe you
have a substance used to sort or not
and if you don't they send you on your
way and say here is your 50 euro fine
now
one of the things that i think is really
important if you start looking at the
empirical research and the science like
last year we arrested over 1.5 million
people for some type of drug violation
right
about 83 of those folks
are for simple possession only
and then let's take a look at the
empirical research the empirical
research will tell you that 80 to 90 of
the people who are using drugs
do not suffer
from a substance use disorder
so right now we are churning people into
the criminal justice system who don't
need to be there that we could deal with
public health interventions in other
ways so under your
example yeah you're still going to have
a law enforcement contact exactly
but
and do what
you're going to go to a dissuasion court
if we adopted true decriminalization
like portugal does exactly and i agree
with you you would go to a dissuasion
court where there's no criminal
penalties you you don't simply pay fine
you you pay a fine or they encourage you
and and we've seen this results in
portugal very conservative catholic
country the reason they went to this is
because their overdose rates was
horrible they've reduced their overdose
death by 50 percent
they have
reduced
aids and hiv because people aren't
sharing needles and there's more people
going into treatment and then you also
have switzerland that does heroin
assisted treatment program under a
prescribed model you have canada right
now in 2020 the canadian police chiefs
came out with a
report a white paper that basically says
in order for us to deal with our
fentanyl illicit poison drug supply i'm
going to say that all the time because
it's an illicit poison drug supply
that is killing
people right now is that they recommend
full decriminalization like portugal the
introduction of safe supply
which is pharmaceutical grade
for people who are suffering from
opioid disorder just like switzerland
does
and then expand interventions like
overdose prevention centers safe supply
safe injection sites if you enjoyed this
short clip give us a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel and if you want
to watch the whole thing click over here